from Cowboy shootouts to shocking scenes
at a Native American Residential School
Taylor Sheridan's 1923 takes viewers
from rural Montana to Africa and Beyond
here's a behind the scenes look at the
latest Yellowstone spin-off
though the flagship Yellowstone Series
has been on the air for Five Seasons
each more intense than the last not
every spin-off has received a second
round 1883 was a one and done limited
series at Creator Taylor Sheridan
himself described as a quote 10-hour
movie with an ending rather than simply
continuing the story in 1923 skips
forward four decades to witness the now
established duttons fight for survival
during Montana's Great Depression but
unlike its predecessor in 1923 earned a
second season with the promise to
continue the exhilarating story of Jacob
and Cara Dutton into another year while
this isn't the first Paramount shared in
co-production to find itself with more
stories to tell it is the first
Yellowstone spin-off to earn a direct
continuation when talking with deadline
about the renewal Sheridan revealed that
the second season would also consist of
Eight Episodes explaining why the 1883
follow-up would be more than a single
season he said I need to do this in two
blocks an eight-episode block and a
second eight episode block to wrap this
up repair mounted is great because they
get more content for me I get more
Runway one thing's for sure we can't
complain about more Dutton Adventures
when Sheridan first announced his new
wave of Yellowstone spin-offs 1923 was
originally billed as a different series
altogether wanting to tell the story of
Montana's Great Depression which began
before the economic catastrophe hit the
rest of America in the 1930s Sheridan
had initially titled the series 1932 but
a deeper dive into Montana's history
changed that by the time the series
entered production the last two digits
in the title had soft rather than
chronicling the Nationwide Great
Depression the series tackles The
Fallout of World War One the 1920s
prohibition era and Montana's own
depression which started nearly a decade
earlier and involved a host of cattle
and range Wars while the premise of a
great depression-era tale is interesting
in and of itself 1923 is unique in that
it can cover multiple eras of American
and world history at once all while
invoking the works of John Steinbeck in
the process no doubt the change served
the series well in the long run allowing
for it to include Spencer dutton's
post-war Voyage to Africa as a higher
gun this has been one of the more
impressive story lines on the series and
has stretched the Yellowstone franchise
into international waters in addition
the commentary on the impulsiveness of
the 1920s mixed with the desperation of
a depression makes for some instantly
dramatic content
he survived the night
[Music]
it's no secret that the year's 1923 and
1883 are more than a couple decades
apart since most of the 1883 cast is
killed off by the limited series and
that leaves very few options for the
Dutton family to continue their
bloodline because of this James dutton's
older brother Jacob and his wife Cara
take over the Dutton Homestead and carry
on the family Legacy in 1923. though
Harrison Ford and Helen Mirren headline
the series there are two others who
bridge the gap from the first prequel in
this one for starters the series is
narrated by actress Isabelle May who
played Elsa Dutton the firstborn
daughter of James and Margaret on 1883.
though Elsa dies in 1883 her spirit
still haunts her family's land and
intends to watch over the Dutton Legacy
from afar May herself is the only cast
member from 1883 to lender talents to
Sheridan's latest prequel vocal or
otherwise of course A young John Dutton
senior was present during the events of
1883 as well played then by Audie Rick
though Rick doesn't return John Senior
is the only character from 1883 to
physically return in 1923 though not for
long while most actors prefer to see a
script before signing on to a commitment
like 1923 neither Harrison Ford nor
Helen Mirren did so though he'd planned
all of 1883 out beforehand Taylor
Sheridan had only a rough idea of where
he wanted 1923 to go but we knew exactly
who he wanted to cast he told deadline
in 2022 I need to know who I'm writing
for I'm done wondering who I'm writing
for and I have to go try to chase the
person I had in my mind and I can't get
the person because they're doing some
other Netflix show this wasn't so with
Ford Mirren in that same interview
Sheridan explained that Ford flew
himself down to Texas to meet with him
in his own private Ranch and he talked
the movie star into it over a bottle of
wine I have what my family fought for
Sheridan went on then came Helen Mirren
and same thing have a glass of wine
Sheridan is quite a reputation in
Hollywood one that flocks big names
towards the Yellowstone Universe in an
interview with a Hollywood Reporter Ford
explained why he took roles on both
shrinking on Apple TV plus and
Sheridan's latest prequel saying I took
the job without a script on both of them
on faith that the people who created the
projects were going to deliver me a good
script
would you believe that 1923 is one of
the most expensive television projects
ever with Harrison Ford and Helen Mirren
on board not to mention the immaculate
set design and production value that
tosses us backwards a century there's no
denying that the latest Taylor Sheridan
Yellowstone series is putting its money
where its mouth is in fact Sheridan told
deadline that he believes 1883 was the
most expensive first season ever made
only for 1923 to exceed that Sheridan
told deadline I don't know what the Game
of Thrones budgets were but I don't know
how they could have been more than this
you're gonna hang us
hey
hang me
in the same interview the filmmaker
estimates they're spending around 22
million dollars per episode saying I
didn't do very good in math in school
but I can Multiply eight and three and
add a bunch of zeros and realize I just
asked for 150 million dollars no doubt
Game of Thrones average 15 million
dollars per episode by its final season
meaning that the budget for 1923 quickly
surpassed it when compared to the
flagship series 1923 cost more than the
first three seasons of the Kevin
costner-led production combined
according to the Salt Lake Tribune
Yellowstone spent somewhere around 80
million dollars in Utah during the
series first few years back when they
used to film there rather than in
Montana with the show's success that
budget is no doubt gotten larger but
certainly not as large as 150 million
dollars total though the Yellowstone
Saga is most well known for shooting
primarily in Montana to change the
franchise made after a few years of
filming in Northern Utah not every plot
line in 1923 revolves around the Dutton
family ranch though the flagship series
primarily shoots in Missoula Montana
1923's time in Montana was mostly
centered in Butte a historic mining town
Butte lies about halfway between Bozeman
and Missoula and gives off a turn of the
century vibe that lends itself well to
the 1920s time period but not every 1923
character resides in Montana as Spencer
Dutton spends a majority of the series
away from the family Homestead his
adventures with Alex take him across
Africa and into international waters in
hopes of reaching the United States but
these scenes weren't shot in some
Hollywood studio darling they're not
words to describe the pickle we just
found ourselves in
we need a higher tree
unlike the other Yellowstone series
which exclusively film within the US
1923 branched out with on location
shooting in Africa the Show's first
season made its way into a few different
countries across the globe including
South Africa Kenya Tanzania and Malta
which is considered part of southern
Europe the production even stopped
bravely in Kabul the capital of
Afghanistan which is technically part of
Asia including North America that's four
continents touched by 1923.
ever since Yellowstone became the
Paramount Network's breakout hit series
The long-running Hollywood studio has
given Taylor Sheridan free reign when it
comes to the Yellowstone universe and
Beyond launching four different series
since the flagship series success
Sheridan has built quite the catalog of
Paramount produced content that only
seems to be growing between the
Yellowstone spin-offs and his other
unrelated stories Sheridan's got it made
when the first episode of 1923 debuted
on Paramount plus it instantly broke
every record as the streamer's biggest
series debut after a 1923 garnered
upwards of 7 million viewers Paramount
media Network CEO Chris McCarthy deemed
it the number one new cable premiere of
the year making the second season a
Surefire thing as the story of the 1920s
band of duttons continues the Intrigue
and mystery surrounding Donald
whitfield's land-grabbing plot grows and
will no doubt continue to bring more
viewers in David C Glasser 101 Studios
CEO said of the screenwriting shared in
scripts attract not only the best actors
working today but the best crew around
we were so fortunate these huge
audiences tune in to be a part of his
Universe every week it's between the
globetrotting spectacle the gorgeous
cinematography and the powerful
performances by Harrison Ford Helen
Mirren and the rest of the phenomenal
cast it's obvious why audiences continue
to show up
when 1923 first aired there was a lot of
initial confusion as to who the
characters are and where they land on
the Dutton family tree to set the record
straight Harrison Ford's Jacob Dutton is
the older brother of Tim McGraw's James
the family patriarch from 1883 though
Jacob and his wife Cara don't have
children they've come to see James's
Sons John and Spencer as their own while
Jon Dies early on his son jack continues
on the Dutton name and Legacy with his
wife Liz fans of 1883 and 1923 might
have been a bit confused by the addition
of Spencer Dutton who doesn't appear at
all on the former series since he hasn't
been born yet but flashbacks to the year
1893 as seen during Yellowstone season 4
revealed that Spencer was born sometime
after the death of his older sister Elsa
though there's some debates as to
whether Spencer or Jack will Father John
Dutton II it's possible that Jack is
actually a younger John himself though
only time will tell
there's no doubt that the works of
Taylor Sheridan are highly praised by
audiences across the country but his
content isn't exactly for the faint of
heart his 2017 movie Wind River features
a horrific rape scene that highlights
the plights of many Native American
women in many episodes of Yellowstone
have shed light on the same though
nothing can prepare audiences for the
brutality of the Indian boarding school
scenes in 1923 which really pushed the
envelope
okay what
prior to shooting actor Sebastian Roche
The Man Behind father Renault reportedly
apologized to his indigenous castmates
not wishing to sugarcoat this dark
chapter in North American history when
talking with TV Insider Roche explained
in 1923 those residential schools were a
blight on our history I think it's a
very important subject matter to talk
about because it's something that we
really don't know about Roche said he
believes that as storytellers their goal
shouldn't be just entertaining audiences
but challenging them with the truth
adding I felt a responsibility as an
actor to be as truthful as I could it's
true that the residential schools were
horrific and as recently as May 2022 the
United States alone has found 53
different burial sites associated with
them now is certainly the time to shed
some light on this horrific period in
history
many of the cast members of 1923 were
forced to endure Taylor Sheridan's
cowboy boot camp to prepare them for the
harsh conditions of Montana Ranch life
Sheridan has a history of making his
worlds feel authentic by hiring
real-life Cowboys like Corey J Smith as
members of the Yellowstone cast Brian
Garrity who plays Dutton ranch hand zane
revealed to E news that Sheridan's boot
camp wasn't exactly a walk in the park
and so we were running on horses
lassoing learning how to learn how to
use like an old six shooter
but one cast member was enforced to
endure the rigorous training prior to
production Harrison Ford got out of it
but only because he's a ranch owner
himself he told The Hollywood Reporter
I've owned horses for 40 years I lived
in Wyoming for 40 years I'm still living
there part-time it's just getting back
in contact with horses really according
to the land report Ford's owned his
jackson-based Ranch since the 1980s
which is all the necessary
qualifications he needs to play a Dutton
if anyone knows what it means to
preserve what's yours it would be Ford
who keeps both his treasured land and
his personal life pretty close to the
chest